DAVID IGNATIUS: If those of you who are still
milling about -- if you could take your seats.
There's a lot of interest in this tonight,
this subject.
We want to get started right off.
We were saying before it's a little intimidating
for us up here on the stage to look out on
you and see -- can everyone hear me OK?
>>MR.
: Yeah.
>>IGNATIUS: No?
>>MR.
: No, I don't think you're on yet.
>>IGNATIUS: We were assured we weren't going
to have to turn these on -- you can hear me
now, right?
Thanks.
We were just saying before we came up here
that it's a little unnerving to look out at
you and see so many well-informed people on
South Asia issues.
It's kind of -- kind of raises the expectations
on us up here on the stage.
We hope we can do our best.
So welcome to today's Council on Foreign Relations
meeting.
I have to begin by asking, as we always do,
for you to turn off your cellphones -- turn
them off, not just put them on vibrate.
As someone who works in radio, I can tell
you that even on vibrate, they can cause electronic
interference with the sound system.
So if you would please turn off all your wireless
devices.
One other point, as a reminder: This meeting,
unlike some council meetings, is on the record.
So that's something for us to keep in mind
as well as you in the audience.
One other announcement: the council is pleased
to announce an upcoming lunch meeting next
-- not next Tuesday -- Tuesday, February 14th:
The U.S. Aging Population as an Economic Growth
Driver for Global Competitiveness.
And the guests for that event are going to
be Joseph Coughlin (sp), Robert Hormats and
Kelly Michael (sp).
For more information on that and other upcoming
events, please refer to the insert in the
back of tonight's program.
So the topic again tonight is U.S.-Pakistan
relations.
And we really do have an all-star panel.
Let me just begin with, to my far right, Steve
Coll.
I'm sure you all know him, president of the
New America Foundation and staff writer for
the New Yorker magazine, before that, a distinguished
foreign correspondent, the author of two -- not
one, two Pulitzer Prize-winning books.
And the one that is of most relevance tonight
is of course "Ghost Wars: The Secret History
of the CIA, Afghanistan and bin Laden from
the Soviet Invasion to September 10th, 2001."
In the middle, Bob Grenier, currently chairman
of EIG Partners.
But for our purposes tonight, he'll be speaking
on the basis of his 27 years of experience
in the intelligence community.
A veteran of the CIA, Bob most recently served
as director of the CIA's Counterterrorism
Center.
Prior to that, he was Iraq mission manager,
and prior to that, the agency's station chief
in Islamabad from 1999 to 2002, in other words,
spanning the 9/11 attacks in that post.
And on my immediate right, Dan Markey, senior
fellow for India, Pakistan and South Asia
here at the council.
And here he specializes in security and governance
issues in South Asia.
He's currently writing a book -- good luck
with that, Dan -- on the future of the U.S.-Pakistan
relationship.
Prior to that, he was -- he handled the South
Asia portfolio in the policy planning staff
at the State Department.
And of course, he was project director of
the council- sponsored Independent Task Force
on U.S. strategy in Pakistan and Afghanistan,
and some of the recommendations of that task
force of course will be the subject of our
discussion tonight.
So tonight we are focusing on one of the most
complex and problematic situations in the
world today: the multifaceted and multilateral
relationship between Pakistan, the United
States, Afghanistan and the Taliban.
I would say that this is a critical moment
in U.S.-Pakistan relations, but we have said
that so many times before that it's become
a cliche.
So rather than make that rather lame observation,
let me just roll off a few of the items that
really set the stage for this discussion tonight.
Going back just to last May and of course
the raid that resulted in the killing of Osama
bin Laden -- and we've since learned that
a Pakistani doctor who provided some of the
key intelligence that made that raid possible
has been arrested and is facing possible treason
charges, just one indication of the rage that
that raid engendered in Pakistan among those
who feel that their sovereignty was violated;
and of course the United States, in September,
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs, Admiral
Mullen, very publicly accusing Pakistan's
intelligence service of supporting the Haqqani
terrorist network, which has been the main
enemy of U.S. forces in Afghanistan, and then
subsequent to that, just two months later,
the U.S. air and helicopter strikes that resulted
in the death of 24 Pakistani troops along
the border when they were caught in the middle
of that and, of course, the Pakistanis again,
in their rage at that violation of their sovereignty,
in their view, ordered an end to U.S. supply
and resupply operations through Pakistan for
operations in Afghanistan; and then, of course,
finally and most recently, the controversy
over the memo allegedly written by Pakistan's
ambassador to the United States, Husain Haqqani,
in which he is said to have asked for U.S.
support to guard against a possible military
coup in Afghanistan (sic) on the part of the
Pakistani army and of course that then provoked
one of the most serious civil- military conflicts
in Pakistan in many years.
So that's not even to mention the broader
context in which all these things are occurring
-- the prospect of a U.S. withdrawal from
Afghanistan in less than two years, and the
preparations that are under way for that including
the possible arrangement of negotiations with
the Taliban in Qatar -- so those are the -- that's
sort of the parameters of the situation that
we're going to be talking about tonight.
Dan, I want to start with you just to give
us like a 30-second summary of where you see
U.S.-Pakistan relations right at this moment.
Where do things stand in terms of, let's say,
the aid, the cutoff of aid, the refusal by
Pakistan to accept aid, the supply line issue?
Sort of, in a -- in a nutshell, where do things
stand right now?
>>DANIEL MARKEY: Well, in a nutshell, we are
currently at a place which is certainly worse
in the bilateral relationship than we've had
since 9/11, there's no doubt.
So, yes, we've seen many crises over the past
few years.
I was just thinking today is my fifth anniversary
here at the council and, as soon as I showed
up, things went haywire.
No connection, of course --
>>MR.
: (Inaudible) -- your area.
>>MARKEY: Yeah, no connection.
But we've seen crisis after crisis.
But, over the past 18 months, it's been a
step-wise series of events, each one knocking
us down from where we were to a point which
is as low as we've seen since 9/11.
Now, in terms of our supply routes into Afghanistan
and so on, I think some of these are sort
of transitory issues.
It sounds like at least some of that will
be reopened in the -- in the next few weeks.
But there's a broader question here and it's
a question that's been certainly on Pakistani
minds over the past two years and, in some
ways, much longer than that, which is how
we intend to resolve this end game in Afghanistan.
And I think, in many ways, that's the context
that they see us in the region.
That's how they perceive us.
And the question in their mind is, how are
we going to leave things?
Are we going to leave Afghanistan the sort
of mess that they -- that we felt we left
it at the end of the Soviet occupation?
Are we going to make it even worse for them,
in a sense, by doing things that might say
privilege an Indian involvement in Afghanistan?
And will the way that we leave it leave us
with a really broken relationship between
Washington and Islamabad?
I think that's the framework.
When you boil it down, they're -- each one
of these incidents that we've seen over the
past year in some ways relates to that and
the deep uncertainty on the part of the Pakistanis
about what our intentions are as we prepare
for this departure that you mentioned in Afghanistan.
>>IGNATIUS: Well, and that would be coming
up in a couple of years and that's where the
United States is positioned right now.
You know, something that all three of you
have observed is in reference to Pakistan's
support for the Taliban or for the Haqqani
network -- all three of you have been able
to -- have focused on sort of the rationality
of that position.
And Bob, I wanted -- I was struck by something
that you write in sort of the classic analysis
of an intelligence professional, talking about
Pakistan's support for the Taliban: "Given
their perception of their national interests
and the lack of effective alternative methods
to pursue them, one can readily see why the
Pakistanis behave as they do.
I may disapprove as an American, but as a
political realist, I cannot fault them."
Do you want to elaborate on that a little
bit?
>>ROBERT GRENIER: That's the problem with
writing.
Somebody's likely to read it at some point.
(Laughter.)
Yeah, you know, the -- one of the real problems,
I think, that we all have in dealing with
Pakistan is it's very difficult to get past
one's emotions.The Pakistanis are maddening
as so-called allies.
They -- often, what they do, even when it's
in their interests, is, frankly, rather ignoble.
Even when we understand it, we certainly can't
approve of it.
And so I think it's a tremendous burden, I
think, for policymakers in dealing with those
issues in the first place.
And then, trying to sell them to a political
public is almost impossible.
But, yeah, I think that for just the reasons
that Dan has just mentioned, at this point,
the U.S. has not decided for itself, I think,
first of all -- nor, clearly, in conjunction
with the Afghan government -- what our posture
is going to look like in Afghanistan; how
are we going to perceive our interests in
the future and how are we going to try to
realize them.
And under those circumstances, it becomes
very, very difficult for the Pakistanis to
imagine what that's going to look like.
And I'm sure that U.S. policymakers are telling
them to some degree what that's going to look
like, but we have very, very little credibility.
And it seems to me that unless and until we
make very clear what will be the limits, if
you will, of Pakistani aspirations in Afghanistan,
we're not going to be able to get to anything
approaching an agreement with the Pakistanis
as to what -- how they will pursue their interests
and how we can work out some sort of a rough
-- a rough joint approach in coming up with
something which at the end of the day will
serve our interests and theirs.
The way things are right now, they assume,
as Dan has said, that we're going to be leaving
very shortly, and the only real ally that
they have, potential ally, is the Taliban,
and they're certainly not going to cut ties
with the Taliban under those circumstances.
>>IGNATIUS: Do you think the Pakistanis actually
know what their -- what the limits of their
activity in Afghanistan should be?
And are they capable of confining themselves
to those limits?
>>GRENIER: Well, I don't think that the problem
is with the Pakistanis being able to confine
themselves.
I think that the problem with the Pakistanis
is getting them to do anything at all, even
in pursuit of their own interests.
People tend to think of -- I mean, we see
written all the time that the Taliban is in
thrall to the Pakistanis, that the leadership
of the Taliban is essentially under their
control.
I don't think that that could be further from
the truth.
I think they have a very complicated relation
with -- relationship with them.
I think they try to influence them in variousways.
They certainly don't control them.
And I don't think they've figured out for
themselves, quite frankly, as to what are
achievable national goals in Afghanistan.
>>IGNATIUS: Steve, I read with great interest
the New York Times story today summarizing
this recent classified report on the state
of the Taliban 2012 that's based on 27,000
interrogations of 4,000 Taliban insurgents.
And I think for me, and I think probably for
a lot of people, one of the lines in that
report that really jumped out was an observation
that many Afghans are already bracing themselves
for the prospect of a Taliban takeover in
Afghanistan.
To what extent would you say that the Pakistanis
are also assuming that?
And again, does that explain their determination
to sort of maintain influence with the Taliban,
because they see themselves as dealing with
the future power in Afghanistan?
>>STEVE COLL: Well, I think it's important
to recognize that their timelines are quite
different than our own.
I mean, they're in the neighborhood forever.
We have a plan that we've announced that has
very specific calendar dates that relate to
our political situation at home and in Europe,
and our fiscal sustainability problems.
And they're not thinking about our timeline;
they're thinking about their own, for obvious
reasons.
And my sense of the best guess -- because
nobody has a crystal ball about Afghanistan
-- that the Pakistani high command, core commanders,
are operating from, is that they're doubtful
that the Pakistani army that -- I mean the
Afghan army that we're -- that we're building
will hold together beyond 2016 or 2018.
They see trouble on the horizon after we go.
And I think part of the way to understand
their caution and passivity now is this thinking
about a longer horizon.
Now, I think the second point I'd make about
that is that I think the Pakistani Army is
genuinely in a pretty weak position.
They've got trouble on the horizon, and they
don't have a lot of cards to play.
We're not their partners in securing their
interests in an Afghan transition, they believe
-- at least we haven't established ourselves,
in their minds, as reliable partners.
They see India, Iran and other interests -- other
neighbors who don't have, in their mind, Pakistan's
best interests at heart, already preparing
for a post-NATO Afghanistan.
And, you know, the Taliban, the Quetta shura
leadership that -- the old Islamic Emirate
leadership that's in Pakistan, and the Haqqanis,
as distasteful and difficult and troublesome
as they are as clients -- and they are difficult
clients, who would like, themselves, to be
free of Pakistani influence and coercion -- are
about the only option that they -- that they've
got.
And so caution and a -- and a longer timeline
makes all the sense in that respect.
>>IGNATIUS: Now, you just had a terrific article
in the New Yorker on Mullah Omar.
And one of the things that I thought was most
admirable about it was the nuance in your
analysis.
I mean, you know, it's so easy for us to just
sort of assume that the Taliban are somehow
operating as puppets of the ISI.
You pointed out that -- actually, that there's
a lot of strains in that relationship.
>>COLL: Yeah, well, certainly the Times report
that you referred to and the document itself,
excerpts of which have now been released,
make clear how the Taliban themselves see
their relationship with Pakistan.
And they are -- Taliban leaders and middle-level
commanders are -- they're Afghans, first of
all.
They wish to operate independently.
They resent the extent of dependency that
they sometimes have on the Pakistani state
for travel documents, for security, for the
security of their family members.
If you're living in exile in Pakistan, and
the Pakistani state knows you're there, and
you're a person of significance in the Taliban
command, you're really not a free -- you're
really not a free man.
You may not be under ISI's control, but you
are certainly under their influence, and you're
dependent upon them in logistical ways.
And another point that Afghans have often
made to me -- and I -- when I was in Kandahar
this last time in December, I heard it again
and again -- you know, from the Taliban's
perspective, if you're trying to even consider
conversion from revolutionary violence into
political negotiation, it is not in your interest
-- it's not viable to enter those negotiations
while being seen by other Afghans as an instrument
of the Pakistani state because that weakens
your own credibility with your countrymen.
The Afghans who are in the Taliban leadership
who are exploring negotiations, I think, would
like to enter those negotiations from the
most independent posture possible.
>>IGNATIUS: Bob and Dan, Steve mentioned the
sort of weakness of the -- of the Pakistani
army, which may strike some as kind of an
odd observation given the role that the Pakistani
army has played in Pakistani politics for
so many years.
But I'm curious what your view is of the position
of the Pakistani army right now vis-a-vis
other institutions in Pakistan and in the
midst of this crisis.
Now, Bob, you wrote that they are, in some
ways, the most competent institution in Pakistan.
And yet you don't seem to thinkthat they're
really in much of a position to exert that
competence right now, it seems.
>>GRENIER: I think that if you view the situation
from the perspective of the senior Pakistani
officer corps, they're in a very difficult
situation.
They are facing multiple insurgencies within
their own country, which they're having a
very difficult time managing.
They are very concerned lest the Afghan-focused
militants in the area combine efforts with
the Pakistan-focused militants against them.
And that's something that they absolutely
have to avoid and is one of the root causes
for some of what we would regard as their
very unfortunate behavior vis-a-vis the Afghan
Taliban.
They have lost a great deal of credibility,
particularly -- well, since the reign of General
Musharraf, and now most particularly since
the raid at Abbottabad.
They don't have the domestic political support
to step in and take over the government if
they felt the need to do so.
And so they are having to make accommodations
all the way around, whether it's to the Americans,
the Afghan Taliban, to their own militants
and to a civilian government, which they don't
like and don't trust.
>>IGNATIUS: And Dan, what does this mean for
the United States?
You know, Musharraf was a very important ally
of U.S. administrations.
You know, does the U.S. have a dog in this
fight?
I mean, what is -- what is the outcome sort
of with -- internally in Pakistan that would
be most favorable to U.S. strategic interests?
>>MARKEY: Well, it's a -- it's a really different
and unusual time in Pakistani history insofar
as, as Bob pointed out, the military doesn't
have the legitimacy, the credibility, the
strength, the political punch that it had
had in previous generations.
And I remember reading not long ago an interesting
Pakistani column that pointed out that not
long ago you would have expected, given the
range of crisis that we've seen over the past
year, that at any given time you would have
seen a Pakistani, probably General Kayani,
come onto the television sometime in the evening
and announce that he had been forced, for
national security reasons, to assert the army's
control over the state.
And yet you haven't seen that.
And you've seen the rise -- and Bob alluded
to this -- of other independent power centers
in Pakistani politics.
It's partially the fact that the army was
tarnished by the years of Musharraf's rule.
It's partially that it was tarnished even
by recent events by being too connected to
the United States, by looking weak, by looking
weak after the bin Laden raid and so on.
It's partially those things, but it's also
the rise of the -- of a more independent media,
of political opposition, politicians and so
on, and by the judiciary, which also has asserted
itself in ways that we'd never seen before
in Pakistani history.
So they do feel -- the army does feel somewhat
more constrained than it has in the past.
And yet, if you peel away some of these pieces,
you see that they're still pulling a lot of
the strings from behind the scenes, particularly
with respect to national security strategy
and to regional strategy.
There's no one else who's really running that
policy other than the army.
So while they feel very constrained and hemmed
in in ways that they haven't before, they
don't have that free hand, and it also makes
it somewhat more complicated to figure out
who's really in charge, because it's not transparent,
yet there's no one else -- the president,
the prime minister, the parliament as a whole,
the public or some other -- you know, you
can't find somewhere else where you would
find that power center.
So it does complicate things for us in a -- in
a diplomatic sense.
And it also -- I think it leads to a certain
amount of stalemate and gridlock in their
own system, and it's not surprising that they
seem sometimes sort of befuddled and caught
unaware by events as they happen and that
we get somewhat contradictory or confusing
outcomes.
>>IGNATIUS: Now, another cliche in talking
about Pakistan is that they view India as
their existential enemy, and you have to sort
of keep that in mind always in analyzing Pakistani
behavior.
Sort of bring up to date on that relationship
and that focus, because, you know, one of
the developments in the last few months that
hasn't gotten a tremendous amount of attention
is the sort of very tentative rapprochement
-- that might even be too strong a word -- between
India and Pakistan; some confidence-building
measures, I think, is probably the best to
categorize it.
And what's the significance of that?
And has this changed at all the strategic
outlook of the Pakistani military and security
forces?
>>MARKEY: And it's interesting; you have seen
this surprising mellowing of the relationship
between, in a sense -- between Islamabad and
New Delhi -- certainly unanticipated in New
Delhi, as far as I can tell.
I think Indians were somewhat caught by surprise
by some of the overtures that the Pakistanis
have made in recent months, including on the
trade front.
The Indians that I spoke with were sort of,
where did this come from?
What's driving this?
And I don't really have an answer, except
for two observations.
One would be that on the part -- on the part
of the Pakistani civilian politicians, there
has been an openness and an eagerness to engage,
particularly on the economic front, with India
for quite some time.
And if given the opportunity, they have been
inclined to seize that opportunity.
So they've moved forward or tried to move
forward on most favored nation status agreements,
to open up a variety of -- trade in a variety
of sectors that had been closed.
At the same time, it appears that the army
may have been looking, as it felt hemmed in
on all of these other fronts, to try to at
least ease the pressure on the Indian front
and therefore open the door a bit to the Indian
politicians -- sorry, to the -- to the Pakistani
politicians to make that overture to India.
But it has only gone so far.
It's not -- this is -- there's nothing that
is irreversible about this.
There's nothing that's really been accomplished
that is concrete.
But it's certainly positive and it's certainly
a welcome change.
>>IGNATIUS: Steve, with all of this as background
-- you know, the situation between Afghanistan,
the Taliban, Pakistan, the United States,
India -- what's your sense of Pakistan's view
of the prospect of negotiations between the
United States and Taliban -- initially kind
of a two-sided negotiation?
It's kind of strange that Pakistan doesn't
seem to be as much of a party to that process
as you might think they should be.
What's your sense of what their view of it
is and their interest in it?
>>COLL: Well, I think they have an interest
in it.
I think they do feel aggrieved about the extent
to which they've been involved.
Whether their grievances are justified or
not is another matter; they feel aggrieved
about quite a lot of things about the U.S.
relationship.
The Afghan government and other parties to
the negotiations, I think probably including
sections of our government, are not persuaded
that putting the Pakistanis in the lead in
this negotiation is a really wise way to get
it started.
So there's been tension about the extent to
which the United States has been briefing
the Pakistanis.
That yielded, I think, over the last six months
or so to a much franker exchange between both
the Pakistanis and the Americans about where
this thing was going, what it was going to
look like.
But I -- my sense is that the Pakistanis have
been reluctant to take risks on behalf of
these negotiations, that it's not clear to
them why it's in their interest to really
put their cards on the table at this stage
for the reasons that I described before in
part, that their timelines are quite different.
We're in a rush because we would like this
all to be wrapped up with a -- with a bow
in time for 2014, but that doesn't make -- that
doesn't align with Pakistani perceptions.
You know, I think there are easy metrics to
test Pakistani decision-making about these
negotiations.
They've -- as I pointed out in The New Yorker
piece, they've remained silent on the desirability
of the negotiations.
They could issue a statement saying, we think
these are a good idea; we think the Taliban
ought to participate.
They could release some important Taliban
figures who are in custody in Pakistan, (the
"Liberator" ?) being the most notable of those,
and perhaps they will over time.
I think that this is not a static stalemate
between the United States and Pakistan.
I think the next -- I think we've possibly
touched bottom in the last cycle.
I don't want to be too bold to predict that
because every time I see my friends, who I've
been in touch with in -- about Pakistan since
the late '80s, they always -- this one friend
of mine has the repeated line, the good news
is next year it'll be worse.
(Laughter.)
And he's been right for about 20 years.
And -- but there's -- there -- there's a sense
that, on both sides, there is activity under
way, one step at a time, to at least clear
the brush.
Husain Haqqani is out of Pakistan; that matter
is resolved.
The crisis between the army and Gilani has
been smoothed over.
The negotiations over transit are under sail
and will probably be resolved.
And outreach is going on.
So I think, over the next six or eight months,
there will be an effort on both sides to try
to define a limited agenda of shared interests
in which the stability of Afghanistan would
loom as an obvious subject because it is in
Pakistan's interest to preventAfghanistan
from cracking up.
There is no doubt that if Afghanistan cracks
up, Pakistan will suffer even more than it
already has from the violence and conflict
in the region and the United States would
also wish to construct a transition in which
Pakistan remains stable and intact as a state
and so that is a pretty powerful common agenda.
It would be irrational if the two sides could
not find a way back to it.
Whether negotiations with the Taliban are
best understood as the central element of
that shared agenda or not, I'm not --
MR.
>>IGNATIUS (?): Yeah.
>>COLL: -- I'm not so sure.
MR.
>>IGNATIUS (?): There's one other issue I
want your thoughts on, and then we're going
to turn it over to the audience so you can
ask your own questions.
But, over the last 10 years, the one enduring
principle guiding U.S. policy with respect
to Afghanistan has been the determination
to deny, dismantle and defeat al-Qaida.
Of course in the eve of -- and you were there,
Bob -- in the eve of the -- going to war in
Afghanistan, the Taliban leadership in power
at that time did have the opportunity to avoid
war by simply getting the al-Qaida out of
Afghanistan.
And now when we talk about these negotiations,
there's a lot of confusion about what the
red lines of the United States are.
But one pretty clear red line is that the
Taliban would have to sever their relations
with al-Qaida.
I'm curious, among all three of you, where
do you see al-Qaida right now in this mix?
Bob, do you want to start?
>>GRENIER: Well, I think, in a way, al-Qaida
is a little bit peripheral in the context
of the dynamics on the ground and among ourselves,
the Pakistanis and the Afghans.
And yes, absolutely, it would be a red line
for us that the Taliban would have to, in
some way, you know, formally, you know, cut
ties with al-Qaida.
The problem is that I'm just not sure what
that would mean.
I mean, at the end of the day, from the Taliban's
perspective, these are good Muslims who are
behaving in the right way, who are coming
to us and asking for our aid and succor.
And they tend to see things -- I mean, we
hear that this is not your father's Taliban
and that they've evolved in terms of their
thinking, but it's hard for me to imagine
them being put in that situation where they
wouldn't see the question in a very binary
way.
And the correct answer, by their likes, is,
well, of course; you are welcome.
Now, they might try to put limits on them.
We've seen what that looks like before.
Given the weakness of al-Qaida, what I've
just said may not matter all that much, particularly
if there is a continuing unilateral U.S. role
in Afghanistan so we can control that situation
with al-Qaida should it get out of hand in
certain localities.
But at the end of the day, I just don't see
what those sorts of promises from the Taliban
would really mean in a practical way.
>>IGNATIUS: Well, Dan, if in fact al-Qaida
is peripheral to this -- to this situation,
I mean, what does that imply for the United
States?
Because every time you ask a U.S. official,
what's the justification for our involvement
there, al-Qaida comes up.
>>MARKEY: Well, I think how a U.S. official
justifies our involvement in the region on
the basis of al-Qaida has something to do
with American politics and so on.
And -- but the -- let me -- let me take a
slightly different stab at the al-Qaida.
I wouldn't say that al-Qaida is peripheral,
although it is significantly diminished.
What I would also observe is something that's
-- getting back to the report from a year
ago, pieces of it are, I think, somewhat dated.
So much has happened over the year.
But one of the pieces that, looking back,
I thought was useful and important --
>>IGNATIUS: You're talking about the task
force report?
>>MARKEY: -- the task force report, yeah -- is
the -- its focus on LeT, Lashkar-e-Taiba.
Not all assessments of the regional threat
from Pakistan and Afghanistan, certainly focusing
more on Pakistan, really emphasize this as
an issue.
And the U.S. government has certainly ramped
up its concern and some of its rhetoric about
LeT, particularly after the 2008 Mumbai attack.
And yet if you look at the region and you
look at al-Qaida as increasingly a diminished
or spent force, the question is whether you're
likely to see follow-on groups, organizations
that are still motivated to undertake similar
types of attacks in the region and globally.
If you had to put your finger on any of the
groups that might be the one, today it's LeT.
And its continuing ties or apparent ties with
the Pakistani state make it exceptionally
dangerous and in some ways unique.
And even over the past few weeks you've seen
stories about its sort of -- he would say
he's no longer the leader of LeT, but Hafiz
Saeed -- you've seen some stories about increasing
public appearances, demonstrations.
This is an organization that is still strong,
still active.
And if we keep -- if we take our eye off that
ball, even if we have seriously decimated
al-Qaida, I think we will be underestimating
the nature of the threat -- the terrorist
threat from the region that will persist for
a significant period of time.
>>IGNATIUS: Steve, do you agree with that,
that al-Qaida is really no longer the story
that it was and that other actors are more
important?
>>COLL: Well, I mean, let's remind ourselves
of the -- of the background.
By 2005-2006 al-Qaida in the tribal areas
had become a revived international menace
-- the planes-bombing conspiracy of 2006,
multiple attacks in Britain, the Zazi case,
up -- moving forward through 2007-2008 after
the Red Mosque, when even more radicals flushed
out and went up to the tribal regions, there
was a gathering there of international capacity
that al-Qaida had put together circa that
period.
Then the United States started pounding them
and has pounded them pretty relentlessly for
a period of two or three years, starting toward
the tail end of the Bush administration, but
picking up intensively in the Obama administration.
And that has had a big impact on them.
They've obviously -- culminating in bin Laden's
killing last May.
Now, there is a -- there is an interesting
question, which is if al-Qaida is diminished
to the point that it is no longer a global
strategic threat, how would we ever recognize
that; what would the implications be?
And I think the critical question is are there
individuals, groups, networks who still intend
to carry out attacks outside the region, and
that there will probably always be some who
-- about whom that can be said.
They may be splinters from groups like Lashkar
and Jaish-e-Muhammad and some of the sectarian
groups.
That's the form of al-Qaida that probably
has the most durability.
You know, in Afghanistan, al-Qaida really
is peripheral.
I mean, it maybe a hundred, 200 people, and
that's being generous to the Uzbeks and others
who fly under the al-Qaida flag.
And the interrogations of the -- of the Taliban,
though you know, obviously, it's in the interest
of detained Taliban to -- they know what the
Americans want to hear about al-Qaida, so
they distance themselves.
But I had this interesting experience in December
where I traveled independently in Kandahar,
so I had to kind of dress local.
And all my Kandahari friends were very anxious
that I look authentic so that I didn't attract
attention to the cars we were riding around
in.
And I remember I went shopping in Kabul to
get all of my Kandahari fashions right.
And --
MR.
>>IGNATIUS (?): Where'd you find a beard?
>>COLL: Well, so I -- well, I did try.
And -- (laughter) -- but I remember -- I remember
-- I remember the night before I flew down,
I looked in the mirror and I said, OK, I do
not look like a Kandahari at all, but I do
look like a Syrian al-Qaida facilitator.
(Laughter.)
And in fact, on the ground, riding around,
I presented as basically al-Qaida to -- because
I was -- looked -- blended dresswise, but
fair -- and all of my Kandahari friends and
contacts and everyone I dealt with said, you
watch; as soon as anyone picks you up, they're
going to turn and run in the other direction.
Nobody wants anything to do with al-Qaida
because it is nothing but trouble.
And it was actually a very useful position
for me to be in.
(Laughter.)
(Chuckles.)
Just turn and look the other way.
But yeah, so I -- and I did not -- I have
not heard in years, outside of a few little
places where -- certainly not in the south
-- of any significant al-Qaida presence in
Afghanistan.
>>IGNATIUS: Yeah.
Well, I'm curious what some of you might think
about the implications of al-Qaida being such
a diminished sort of part of the narrative
in South Asia right now.
I'm been dragging these guys hither and yon
all over the strategic landscape in South
Asia.
Maybe you folks can focus this discussion
a little bit more.
So this is your chance.
Raise your hands.
Identify yourself.
Wait for the microphone.
You know the drill.
Ambassador Schaffer.
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Tezi Schaffer, Brookings.
I'm troubled by all three presentations because
I think all three of them dramatically underplay
the conflict in strategic objectives between
the United States and Pakistan.
I don't think the Pakistanisare ambivalent
about U.S.-Taliban negotiations; I think they
want to be in charge.
I don't think they're unwilling to take risks
for an outcome in Afghanistan that the U.S.
would find acceptable.
I think that's not what's important to them.
What's important to them is being the dominant
power and freezing out India.
The key question facing the U.S., it seems
to me, is, is Pakistan willing and able to
reach some kind of strategic agreement with
the United States?
I am deeply skeptical that this is the case
now, not just because of all the emotion churned
up in the past year, but also because as time
has gone on, these strategic conflicts have
become deeper and edgier, so that a year or
two ago, there would've been a strong case
to make for the U.S. humoring Pakistan's sensitivities
in Afghanistan in the hopes of getting agreement
on some outcome we could all live with; I
think that case is much weaker now.
And I think is the big problem the U.S. faces,
plus the fact that Pakistan is a bigger prize
than Afghanistan.
>>IGNATIUS: Who wants to take a crack at that?
>>MR.
GRENIER (?): Well, I agree with Tezi.
(Chuckles.)
In fact, I think that that's absolutely right.
I think that the Pakistanis are focused like
a laser beam on their own interests.
And under these ambiguous circumstances, they
have no assurances that their interests will
be taken into account by any process which
is led by the United States.
And I think that you're right, that the influence
of India in Afghanistan figures very, very
heavily within the Pakistani calculation.
And so I think that if there is any hope for
us to reach some sort of a strategic accommodation
there, I think we have to realize a couple
of things.
One is that, as much as we would like to sort
of have the equal involvement of all of the
-- of the neighbors of Afghanistan, in fact,
there is one neighbor that counts much more
than all the others, and that's Pakistan.
It's just a reality and something that we
have to accommodate, at least to some degree.
I think that it's also true, therefore, that
any achievable accommodation in Afghanistan
that could have some support from the Pakistani
side would require a great deal of difficult
negotiation between ourselves -- well, I guess,
amongst ourselves, the Afghans -- if you will,
the Northern Alliance-dominated Afghans -- and
India.
And it's easy for me to sit here and say that
it would be a grand exercise in enlightened
self-interest if the Indians were to pull
back to some degree in Afghanistan.
It's going to be very, very difficult to convince
them of that, however.
But the other real trump in all of this is
that, you know, it would be nice if, at the
end of the day, we could reach some sort of
an -- of an accommodation with the Afghan
parties and with the Pakistanis, which we
might not particularly like, but we'd swallow
hard and agree to if the Pakistanis could
deliver.
And I just don't think that they can deliver.
I mean, I sort of fantasize about havingsort
of a Bashar al-Assad-type conversation with
the Afghan Taliban where he sits down and
says, look, you know, you're my brothers.
And we are with you, and we want to do everything
we possibly can for you, but this is the best
we can do.
And it's up to you whether you accept it,
but you should accept it.
There's no one in Pakistan who can have that
kind of conversation with them, and that,
to me, is what scotches the whole thing.
If the Pakistanis could actually deliver at
the end of the day, we could use some kind
of a deal.
I just don't see how they can deliver.
>>COLL: But you know, I would just add -- I
mean, Pakistan has a record of miscalculation
in Afghanistan that is just appalling and
persistent.
It must reflect in a failure to understand
Afghanistan adequately to manage Pakistan's
own interests there.
They've picked the wrong clients again and
again.
They -- they'll lecture Americans about how
Afghanistan is, but in fact their understanding
of Afghanistan's internal dynamics, factions
and decision-making is misguided.
They misapprehend India's intention and presence
in the country to a great degree.
And they make -- they've made strategic judgments
on the basis of bad analysis.
Now, I think there is some recognition in
Pakistan -- quiet, unadmitted -- I don't -- I
-- which shouldn't be a requirement that they
come forward and confess these errors publicly;
they're written into history.
I think there's a recognition, at least in
some quarters, that these mistakes are grave
and part of a pattern of overreaching.
And there's -- you know, there's a sort of
tentative search for, well, what would a Pakistani
strategy in Afghanistan that wasn't overreaching
look like?
And I haven't heard an articulation of that
from the Pakistani side that any Afghan I
know in a position of authority would recognize
as a plausible basis for a settlement.
So, at best, you could say we're at the very
beginning of a new imagination.
But then you look at Pakistani conduct, and
Pakistani conduct is the "same old, same old"
--
>>IGNATIUS: Now you --
>>COLL: -- whether it's out of weakness or
aspiration.
>>IGNATIUS: Well, you said before that they
speak -- that they think in the long term;
yet in some ways it seems like they have a
very short-term perspective and kind of, as
you've all agreed, kind of lack strategic
sort of depth in their thinking sometimes.
>>COLL: Yeah, they have a language of strategy
and certainly enduring interests and an acute
sense of prerogative about Pakistan's national
security, you know, which is -- which is the
-- justified in any sovereign country in principle.
But as to Afghanistan, they have proceeded
from flawed assumptions about the pliability
of Afghanistan to their strategy, about who
-- what clients are durable, about the nature
of power- sharing in Kabul, about the enmity
of the Northern Alliance.
I mean, they've miscalculated on big questions
again and again.
>>IGNATIUS: Chris.
>>QUESTIONER: Thanks.
Chris Isham from CBS.
I think we're kind of dancing around something
here, and I wonder -- maybe the land of fantasy
-- it's unclear to me what kind of a deal
might possibly exist.
What kind of a deal could we negotiate with
the Taliban, with Pakistan, as their supporters,
that could even be conceivably realistic?
I mean, India out, girls' education, participation
in the democratic process -- I mean, you know,
what kind of a deal, even in -- even in the
fantasy world do you -- do the three of you
think could you possibly put on the table
that might have a chance of getting off the
ground?
And also considering that the unpopularity
of the Taliban, which continues -- we continue
to see in the polling.
>>COLL: Well, I mean --
>>IGNATIUS: Go ahead.
MR.
: Sorry.
>>COLL: Well, I mean, it's just worth pointing
out there are former Taliban sitting in Parliament
now.
There are former HezB (ph) sitting in Parliament
History is full of insurgent movements that
converted to politics.
So the idea generally would be to convert
the Taliban into a political party or some
section of the Taliban into a political party.
Obviously not every Taliban under arms -- and
perhaps not even half of Taliban under arms
-- would follow such an agreement, but to
reduce violence, to sustain the state in Afghanistan,
it's certainly conceivable that a section
of Taliban could be persuaded to enter politics.
That's the -- I'm not offering odds; I'm just
saying that's the conceivable framework.
And then power-sharing in the center, but
not control; it -- devolved administration
in which former Taliban are governors of provinces
where they've historically been influential.
Those are the sorts of things that people
talk about.
Even Afghans talk about that.
Afghans can imagine a stable -- a semistable
power-sharing arrangement.
They've already negotiated such an arrangement
with weakperipheral members of the Taliban.
They know how to make those deals sustainable.
But whether a strategic partnership of that
type is conceivable, that's another matter.
>>IGNATIUS: Go ahead -- go.
MR.
: All right.
>>MARKEY: I would only make the observation
that it doesn't have to be a grand bargain
that everybody's included, and I think you're
alluding to this.
The process of a reconciliation dialogue can
be primarily geared towards a narrower goal
of peeling elements of the Taliban away, those
who are willing in some way to be co-opted
or encouraged to be a part of some sort of
future Afghan politics.
And the rest can be further driven to sort
of the irreconcilable category, and then dealt
with in other ways.
I think a broader observation, though: I'm
also quite skeptical about the direction that
our reconciliation agenda is taking, but for
a different reason and a -- and a reason that
has, I guess, more to do with Pakistan than
with Afghanistan -- although I'm -- I don't
know how a lot of Afghans would accept any
kind of reconciliation.
But just on the Pakistan side, the message
that we send to Pakistan, particularly when
our reconciliation dialogue is increasingly
open to all members of the Taliban, including
the Haqqani network -- or at least apparently
that way -- is that their strategy, their
connections with these groups over the past
decade that we have harped on again and again
and again as being dangerous both to them
and to us and to the region -- their strategy,
in their mind, looks like it's working; that
we're coming around -- and I've heard exactly
this -- that we're coming around to their
vision of the problem, which is that all of
these groups can be incorporated and all of
them should have a role to play in Afghanistan,
no matter what blood is on their hands or
what their -- the nature of their previous
relationship with al-Qaida may or may not
have been.
As we come closer to that, I think we send
-- it's a missed opportunity, in a sense,
for what you might call a learning moment
for Pakistan to see the danger of its connections
with these types of organizations.
And as I mentioned Lashkar-e-Taiba before,
the only sort of logical conclusion that you
might reach out of all of this is that connections
with militants work; it is a valuable and
effective tool for regional diplomacy.
And if you're a Pakistani, you might have
good reasons to hold onto those tools into
the future, even when they are exceedingly
difficult to manage and exceedingly dangerous
to Pakistan itself and certainly court the
possibility of a future conflict between Pakistan
and us, between Pakistan and India, and so
on.
So I'm worried about reconciliation more for
that reason.
And I believe that our management of the process
and who's in and who's out is meaningful and
interpreted in important ways by Pakistanis
for that reason.
>>IGNATIUS: Yes, to you, ma'am -- you, yeah.
>>QUESTIONER: Avis Bohlen, retired diplomat.
I -- I'm sort of puzzled by something I'm
hearing several of you saying, which is that
Pakistan doesn't understand its own interests
in this -- in this situation; which implies
that somehow we have understood what their
interests are and are -- you know, are sort
of looking at it from up above and can understand
what their greater -- what their greater interest
is.
That doesn't really make a lot of sense to
me.
I mean, I think we've -- for every miscalculation
that Pakistan may have made in Afghanistan,
we've made about 10.
Why is it impossible that they should -- as
you've said, there's a longer timeline, and
they're looking at a longer situation and
how it will evolve over time.
Why is that not a perfectly valid definition
of their own interest, which may not be very
much in line with our own?
And just a second short question.
Is India's interest in Afghanistan strategic
or opportunistic, economic?
What's its game?
>>GRENIER: Well, maybe I could just address
the first part of that.
>>IGNATIUS: Yeah.
>>GRENIER: And I guess -- I guess what I would
say is that even if the combined genius of
the people on this stage is able to perceive
Pakistani interests in Afghanistan better
than they can -- even if we accept that -- it
doesn't matter, because at the end of the
day, Pakistanis are going to follow their
interests as they perceive them.
We're going to have to play that ball where
it lies.
And, yes, it can be moved, perhaps.
They are not -- they are not completely immune
to some types of suasion -- not pressure,
but suasion.
But at the end of the day, Pakistani views
of their interests in Afghanistan are what
they are, and we're going to have to deal
with them as they are.
>>IGNATIUS: One of the points that you've
made, Bob, is that this whole idea of carrots-and-stick
and the transactional sort of approach just
doesn't work with Pakistan.
>>GRENIER: Well, I think that that raises
another question.
And that is that at the start of the -- of
this administration, I was one of the ones
in one of the many studies who said, look,
we have to get away from this transactional
dynamic here; we really need to develop some
more of a strategic approach to our relations
with Pakistan.
You know, we'll -- for the long term, we'll
-- I think we've reached a point now where
any kind of a transactional relationship would
actually look pretty good.
(Laughter.)
So I think that the best we can hope for,
at least in the short term, is, yes, a transactional
relationship, but a transactional relationship
that's focused on deals that are actually
makeable.
>>IGNATIUS: Steve?
>>COLL: Well, let me just clarify the point
that I was making earlier.
I think Pakistan has a record of failing to
achieve its own objectives in Afghanistan.
After the withdrawal of the Soviet Union,
it pursued a (coup-making ?) strategy to seize
control of Kabul through Gulbuddin Hekmatyar's
forces and failed to do that.
Afterwards it sought to control Afghanistan
as a -- as a source of strategic depth, as
Pakistani generals put it, through the Taliban.
The -- even after they installed the Taliban
in power in Afghanistan, that proved not to
be a durable strategy because the Taliban
were not in fact able to carry Pakistan's
interests in the way that the army had conceived.
That's the reason that I think they have miscalculated
again and again.
I certainly agree that whatever they -- you
know, that the sovereign state of Pakistan
will decide its own interests for itself.
And countries, like people, have a funny way
of not bending to other people's perceptions
of what their interests are.
The -- I think, however, that history of failure
is important because it was created by a narrow
set of institutions in Pakistani national
life, the army and the intelligence services,
and that the policies that would be constructed
by a Pakistan that enjoyed more normal civil-military
relations and, indeed, more normal civilian
control over foreign policy, would be far
more likely to succeed.
And coincidentally, they would also align
better with the interests of the United States
over the long run.
But the record of failure speaks for itself,
and it is not a record that was created by
a unified or civilian-led Pakistani government.
>>IGNATIUS: Dan, you had a quick point.
>>MARKEY: Yeah, just a quick observation on
India.
Yes, it does, I think, have a strategic interest
in Afghanistan.
That relates to an interest that's similar
to ours, which is that they've suffered from
terrorist acts that have originated in Afghanistan.
They have an interest in making sure that
they don't see a return to a Taliban or Taliban-like
regime that would play host to those kinds
of groups.
So that's their first interest.
Beyond that, some Indians have greater ambition
for more access to Central Asian -- Asia,
to energy markets and so on that would only
really be possible if there was a relatively
stable Afghanistan through which they could
traverse.
But it would also require them tobe able to
get through Pakistan for the most part, unless
they went through Iran.
>>IGNATIUS: You had a question?
>>QUESTIONER: Hi, Pamela Constable from the
Washington Post.
Just a quick point of order: Did I understand
or mishear -- is this in fact on the record?
>>IGNATIUS: Yes, it is on the record.
>>QUESTIONER: OK, great.
Thanks.
I sort of wanted to change the conversation
a little bit.
We've been talking a lot sort of state to
state and organization to organization and
talking about al-Qaida and other groups as
sort of almost formal entities.
I've tried to explore both countries sort
of more from the inside, sort of more in terms
of public opinion and public sentiment.
Very glad Dan talked about LeT, because I
think -- and in fact, I'd like to ask Steve
about this as well, because the New America
has done some very, very good polling.
LeT is a popular organization.
The Taliban are a popular organization.
In both of these societies, we are looking
at populations -- Muslim populations who are
both more conservative, more emotionally defensive
and supportive about sort of a muscular version,
if not necessarily a violent version, of Islam
than we, I think, were expecting or necessarily
prepared to deal with.
I think we've been focusing a lot militarily
and a lot, again, state to state, making assumptions
about who's in power.
These are both very weak states, including
the Pakistan army, facing increasingly opinionated,
vocal and violent populations who are -- have
very, very strong feelings about Islam and
are increasingly anti-Western.
So I was hoping that the speakers could comment
on sort of what they see about happening in
both of these societies as well as the state
actors and the organizations that we've been
talking about.
Thank you.
>>IGNATIUS: Steve, why don't you take a crack
at that, because you've got recent on-the-ground
experience there, and I want to get to some
other questions.
>>COLL: Well, just to speak of Pakistan, Pakistan
is a very young society.
It's also a very plugged-in society, and it
has a lot of the demographic and connectivity
characteristics that preceded the Arab Spring.
I think the rise of confidence in civil society
and the media and the judiciary reflects a
sense that Pakistan is changing from the bottom
up.
And I think the army recognizes that, and
that's why they would, I think, be unwise
and recognize they would be unwise to intervene
in politics the way they have in the past,
as Dan was pointing out earlier.
They're -- the polling -- one -- somebody
mentioned before about the role the United
States now plays in the life of Pakistan.
We did a -- some polling recently, where it
was sort of startling to realize that many
more Pakistanis regard the United States as
an enemy than regard India as an enemy.
Considering that at the time that we did that
polling, India had recently concluded what
you might call its fourth war with Pakistan
in 1999, and we were providing substantial
aid to the country, the sense of being under
siege, I think, is very widely felt in the
country.
>>IGNATIUS: Well, we're going to have to wrap
this discussion up.
I got time for one more quick question.
I see Joe back there.
And then you can grab us afterwards or something,
but quick question from Joe Cirincione..
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Thank you very much for comments.
Joe Cirincione, Ploughshares Fund.
And thank you, Tom (sp), for your fluid chairing
of this insightful panel.
Next week I'm going to a meeting where I'm
expected to give recommendations for U.S.
policy towards Pakistan, and I have no idea
what to say.
(Laughter.)
So help me out.
Give me the one thing, each of you, that the
U.S. should be doing with Pakistan that it's
not doing now.
>>IGNATIUS: One sentence each.
Dan, you're a policy planning guy, so you
can start.
>>MARKEY: Sure.
I'll go -- I will -- I will take the safe
route -- go back to a recommendation that
was in our task force report, which has been
made for about a decade now and still hasn't
been acted upon, and it has to do with our
trading relationship with Pakistan.
There's a -- there's an opportunity there
in the textile sector to open up.
Now, this is politically dead on Capitol Hill
right now because nobody is particularly eager
to do more for Pakistan.
But once we hopefully get back to a position
where we recognize that Pakistan's -- excuse
me -- longer-term stability is of a meaningful
significance to us, and we start to ask how
we might do that without spending billions
-- tens of billions of dollars in aid, trade
starts to look more palatable.
>>IGNATIUS: Bob?
>>GRENIER: I guess my first piece of advice
would be figure out what the U.S. posture
in Afghanistan post-2014 is going to look
like, and then get there as quickly as you
can and as credibly as you can, because unless
we can communicate that in a credible way,
we won't have the basis on which to reach
a whole series of other agreements with the
-- with the Pakistanis.
And a whole series of decisions on the part
of other players will be predicated -- (from
?) the part of the Pakistanis, the part of
the Afghan Taliban and others -- on what the
continuing U.S. posture in Afghanistan for
the long term is -- (inaudible) -- going to
look like.
>>COLL: Yeah, I think the record of failure
of U.S. policy in Pakistan is informed, you
know, by this pattern of constantly privileging
short-term security crises over long-term
civilian control over the country and the
development of normal civil-military relations
in Pakistan, as well as a pattern of coming
and going in emotional states every 10 years.
And so I would wish to reset, since resetting
is now necessary, around a long -- a clear,
durable, long-term commitment to civilian-
led democracy in Pakistan as articulated by
Pakistanis themselves.
That is what Pakistan wishes for itself.
It has a constitutional system that has often
produced very flawed civilian leaders.
That policy does not require the diminishment
of the army's role in protecting Pakistan's
borders and national security, but it does
mean returning to the first principles of
American relations with big, large quasi-democracies
like Pakistan, which to have the courage of
our own convictions.
Even at every moment that we're tested, we
are often -- we often mute ourselves in the
context of Pakistan in ways we would never
would in Indonesia or Tunisia or even Colombia
or Mexico.
And so I think that we've got to stop deterring
ourselves from the pursuit of this -- of the
Pakistan that so many Pakistanis themselves
envision.
>>IGNATIUS: Well, Joe, I get -- you've got
some talking points now.
And I hope that -- (laughter) -- I hope that's
helpful.
Well, I'd like to thank Steve Coll and Bob
Grenier and Dan Markey for coming.
I'd like to thank you all.
(Applause.)
And let me point out that if a veteran reporter
like Pam Constable was confused about whether
we were on the record, we should reaffirm
this was on the record.
Thanks.